I asked Kevin and Larry not to stand up
because they were already taller and I
was sitting in the book and when they
were sitting there the girls kept coming
up to me while I was by the door
yeah by the door checking IDs and I told
them though that they showed me a
kittycat
there are old enough to come in but none
of them went advanced with Larry or
Kevin and I'm going really you don't
want to dance with them just just cuz
you're older you grab a hold of them by
the back seat and then you reach up and
you look up at us and your belly buttons
is above rigas careers gigs in my life
Carnegie Hall you're gonna have a blast
right I never let the right date
underneath there I can't remember
thank you for being in this video with
you man I appreciate you know they come
back the next day and left a hundred
dollar bill